o laudo diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
lugar que sejam muito bem vindos já é
mais um bdr o que não sei se vocês já
pararam uma estátua chuva a dor se torna
ainda por cima não é aquela chuva que
sofre mesmo é tipo aquela chuva que
parece que jesus está que expira em cima
de você gosta do estilo abaixo o vídeo
de hoje vai ser uma coisa que você já
pedem algum tempo e eu também não traga
um tempo e é uma compilação dos melhores
sustos e irrigações de 2000 não surgirem
ações número 4 espero que vocês gostem
nesta compilação já sabem lá e favorito
baixo nesta segunda os falsos que você
está em todo dia e é isso fique bem e
até a próxima
6 porque tac tem de estar atento às
formas meus novos não funciona é esperto
não funciona um posto militar pm luiz
tavolaro canalho está muito alto a
intuição liga ou desliga isso ai a minha
cueca já tá aí já não saí já não sei se
os shoppings funcionam hoje surgiu coisa
que se poderia ficar sem bateria foi a
filha era lá isso vai vai
a outra estrela foi próspera lá visitar
a loja tão fish
ai ai ai
já não é feio como é que o shopping tudo
até agora nada do governo fred não sei
se vai perceber agora no início não
conseguiram disseram isso estas possuem
tv brasil e lupas a porta continuava na
mesma chave o google acaba de me
assustar com vinho vinho games quando
vim dentro do armário
pronto agora não substitutas ti meu deus
eu entro aqui como é que eu trouxe minha
porta fechada foi na volta a fechar uma
porta acharam uma porta os contos
conosco dentro da banheira rápido a
desculpa desculpa ela lhe desse número
já não ia eu vou tentar
tinha a porta fechada e eu fui na volta
tenho certeza absoluta não precisa
instruções de uso
ela quer um abraço ela quer um everest
em uma zona do euro voltaram a abrir
sendo um é mão eo rock agora já tenha
mais cuidado em cima aí eu sou é mentira
12 foi padrinho de uma churrasqueira
todo mundo
a marreta ainda precisar estou aí que
ela cama tashi do google também em 4 de
manhã
não não não não não conseguisse a herói
o que isto disse ao tudo e deixe morrer
ou indo é esse amigo passo já tinha
clima nos rios e lagos membro para
fechar e eu já nem sei que eu tenho a
dizer mas já tem a investir em cima da
cama
ai meu deus meu eu tenho um foco em
boneco pendurado num quadro morto aqui
ae
houve um rali da fox a rádio no meu
quarto anos
esta foto do gato entrou dentro do fogão
vendas grupos aproveita sempre quando eu
vou ver a porta esquerda - a juventus
pela já conseguiu estudar num burro é
esta festa espera lá foi lá que traz a
quimioterapia e ganhos nos preços os
lados do espectro final não conseguiu
visitar não conseguir somar os dois para
ver jesus amou os até agora porque o
pneu do carro fox e que é minha eu não
ia abrir a porta e mpb com ele como
estamos na noite trecho mas o ai ai meu
deus
ae
como é que conseguiu esta proeza não
sair mas vamos lá
ai eu tá aqui eu tô aqui está muito alto
meu mundo com um molho branco
não não era senão buscar as taxas e
nulos botafogo e meu cérebro e não este
tipo de substância - a biblioteca vai
não dá não dá pra ficar hostil não tá
num parece está tudo tranquilo não vejo
nenhum